I have Steve Harvey's email you on it
yeah yeah really okay good morning
everyone welcome back
there will be no meetings in my dressing
room no stopping by or popping in no one
do not come to my dressing room unless
invited do not open my dressing room
door in all caps if you open my door
expect to be removed my security team
will stop everyone from standing at my
door who have the intent to see or speak
to me I want all the ambushing to stop
now
you must schedule an appointment do not
approach me while I'm in that makeup
chair unless I ask to speak with you
directly either knock or use the
doorbell
do not wait in any hallway to speak to
me I hate being ambushed please make an
appointment I promise you I will not
entertain you in the hallway and do not
attempt to walk with me if you're
reading this I mean you everyone do not
take offense to this new way of doing
business it's for the good of my
personal life and enjoyment
thank you all Steve Harvey he has every
right I mean it's it's they try to get a
petition I think that 25,000 people
signed like trying to get them fired
whoa why I don't I have agree but that's
the age we live in now where people can
get online and make it a social thing
you know no it's his right sure it's his
show it's this show he can do what he
wants I said you really want the
pressure of having a you know entertain
the boss I'd rather keep distance I
don't need to bury myself in my job
because I said something stupid to Steve
that like I don't we don't know what's
going on in his personal life you know
from like anxiety or some type of like I
don't think what happened which someone
was really intrusive mm-hmm that was
like jerking off and some [ __ ] PA
walked in that could have been me
because he did say that he used to have
a mr. Brian he used to have a lenient
policy but that's probably you know
their boundaries yes yeah I don't think
that that's bad honestly
what would your email what would be your
demands well I mean I mean here's the
one thing that I when I was on my animal
practice
[ __ ] it what would you say practice and
you know I could see the first day
because when you're on a show like that
you have to kind of hire the same extras
every week because they're in the
background and they're kind of regular
so the regular extras and a couple of
them were open mike rizzo I would did
open mic with Wow you know man back in
the comedy store back in the 90s oh
right yeah so I'm like talking to the
director about a scene and I can see two
of them in my peripheral approaching
Bobby and they hug you and then everyday
they can't talk to you yeah as if you
know they're on the show - yeah
what's the are let me see something
it's fine being an extra it is but we're
in this environment right sure
don't be real well I I wouldn't do that
why did well I'm not tonight no I hope
them every day yeah for [ __ ] three
months of that thing right I saw them in
the hallway out to talk to them hug them
yeah this is internal what I'm thinking
yeah man why do I have to do this I
don't I don't I don't like like I'm very
funny because I I wouldn't have I would
try not to ever have my phone on set I
like to I like to be very prepared if I
had which is crazy to think at a
multicam but if I had a scene like my
episode my dad shows we don't have a
good relationship season one and
everybody else is on their phone they're
all comics those are the only times I
would ever get a little snappy and just
like don't I'm trying to figure this out
yes I'd rewrite like 40 pages right
three hours before we'd shoot so they
trying to memorize it and then I was so
[ __ ] hard on myself that I wouldn't
want people around me if I felt like I
did that there are you know so yeah I
get that if somebody feels comfortable
do what I hit when they when they when
you you're about to shoot you have new
lines yeah
and you
what I hate when with the sound it's
like you don't you have to memorize
these new lines yeah and they're like up
your shirt it's gonna put the sticky
thing on your chest yeah it's I hate and
yeah makes you a little hey what were
you gonna say it up all right no no I
mean just for common courtesy and a
little bit of common sense I would never
try I would always want someone to have
their space yeah and especially if
they're the performers and that's
already a high-pressure situation I
would never try to start conversation
with anybody that's about to be on
camera sure it's just like when if I
would have to take an exam say for
instance and I all that information is
in my head I don't want any distractions
I don't want my but that bubble of
information to be burst open so don't
[ __ ] talk to me I don't like people
in the hallway hearing them study I
remove myself and I get that I if I if I
had to perform I don't want you in my
[ __ ] space at all sure performers why
would you want anything to distract you
from what you're about to do yeah and if
I start working again